n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir de qui
que ce soit
nous n'avons jamais été prise en défaut
sur la force de nos convictions et sur
la crédibilité de notre positionnement
qui a été sans compromission depuis 2010
est notre résolution est immense elle
est à la hauteur des attentes de nos
concitoyens et ils savent pouvoir
compter sur nous alors madame la
première ministre je les dis nous ne
voterons pas cette motion de censure
mais vous l'avez compris vous n'avez pas
notre défiance aujourd'hui mais vous
n'avez pas notre confiance pour autant
nous jugerons votre gouvernement sur ses
actes et sur sa capacité à construire
dans le respect des uns et des autres
sur un certain nombre de sujets nous
pourrons sans doute agir ensemble avec
pour ambition prioritaire de redonner à
la france son unité et sa place dans le
monde travailler dans l'intérêt des
français et nous serons avec vous
décevez l'el une nouvelle fois et nous
serons vos premiers opposants